*dead inside*
MARKIMOO?!
M: Hello everybody!
M: my name is markiplier
M: this is tyler
M: who are you?
E: heypass
M: heepass?
T: haha E: HAHA
E: haha
yeah thats me
E: good ol heapass (oh)
*hehe time with markimoo*
M: we gonna make leg-oh
*lego noises*
M: thasswhat we got right here
*more lego noises*
*stop the legonoises.mp3*
M: were gonna be makin lego we each have different lego baxes
M: bUuUUUUuUuuUuT!
M: we dont know what they look like
M: we never seen these before
M: you guys can see what we are trying to make right now (i cant?)
M: 'cause ill put a graphic of it later ill put it in insert shot(oh shit)
M: of us holdin up the baxes or somthin like that
M: but we dont know what they look like
M: all we kinda know is that theyre cars
M: *looks at Tyler* T: *yes boss*
M: MAYBE
M: it might be something else
M: its up to the invention and imagination ME: ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
M: but these are supposed to work
these are the type of legos that are actually supposed to move
so......
E: On their own? (worrying)   M: Yeah
(Worry intensifies)
E: huh
M and E: (Laughing)
M: Heapass T: Heapass! E: Heapass!!
E: You've know me for 3 or 4 years now and you don't know my name
M: wanna step on the gas, you call heapass
M: turn that shit to glass, you call heapass
M: you wanna smoke some grass, you call heapass
T: wanna test the pass, you don't call heapass
E: (Mimics the action of eating ass)
M: eat ass, drive fast, smoke grass
M: eat ass, heapass
M: I was in the middle of a bit. T: damnit
M: you see when I am talking in my bit and then you talk that is not how that works
M: MY BIT MY BIT and MY BIT is ruined its all gone
E: You know you really made heapass angry (angry heapass sound)
E: You won't like it when heapass gets angry
(giggling like idiots)
M: So a little history of legos, I think these are legos, are these legos
M: Yeah I'm getting confirmation from the studio these are legos
E: Is playmobile made by lego
M: Lemme get a confirmation on that one
M: we don't know
T: Lego Group M: alright these are legos
M: so a little backstory on legos
M: legos were originally made by a Nasa scientist
M: when he was trying to make a more portable form of brick
M: bricks big heavy, we want small, so he took a normal
brick and put it in a microwave and it magically started
congealing into a tiny itty bitty brick
M: and then he gave it to his kid or something and his kid was like WOW
this is super fun, this is great, I love this dad
I finally have some reason to love you
M: and the dad was well shit like I have to microwave some more bricks
I don't know how to make my kid love me other than this
so he started microwaving bricks and eventually he came up with this
M: Legos
T: by the way it was a special NASA microwave
T don't try microwaving bricks at home
M: you can microwave a brick at home what's wrong with that
T: it might have metal in it and make big boom
M: brick don't have metal in them
T: they could M: kids microwave bricks right now
M: go to your house, take a hammer, smash a brick out of your house
M; grab that brick, pop that badboy in a microwave
M: see what happens
M: I Bet it won't blow up
E: see what happens I bet your parents will lose their deposit if they're renting the house
M: yeah exactly
M: you wanna live fast, follow heapass rules
M: microwave a brick
M: fuck
M: heapass don't know what heapass is doing
M: heapass lives life on the edge
M:  yeah this is bizarre because I don't have wheels
M: Don't start, what are you doing
T: (Silence)
M: No explain what were you doing
T: I was putting a tire on...
M: your bowl is in the way, you can't
M: recycling
M: yeah so take it off
M: alright that's really funny and clever and frankly that's why everyone loves you
M: but please stop it right now
M: what are you doing
E: don't you dare talk to heapass like that
M: you're right, I apologise
M: what are you doing E: I'm building a car
M: well could you stop??
E: alright
E: (Light giggling)
M: take em out
(First slam and yell)
(Another slam and yell)
(Slow mo slam and yell)
(Confused Tyler)
M: ok, so I say 15 minutes is a good amount of time to try to build a lego thing
M: and whoever is closest to the design, whoever is most true to what it is
M: and whosevers works the best is the winner
M: makes sense
M: 15 minutes, put it on the clock we will go on your go
M: ok so I am starting out by figuring out what pieces look like other pieces
M: because I am assuming this has some sort of symmetry right?
E: what do you think yours is, if you dont have wheels
M: wait i got wheels
M: wait they are tiny
M: why are my wheels tiny?
E: listen its not about the size of the wheels
M: yours are really big
E: Oh it's a boat
E: It's a w-
E: Youre building a duck boat!
M: I'm just worried that like they got you like
Sweet awesome teenage... like level
Legos
And I got some whimpy baby
T: I don't know your's said "power"
E: Teenage "level" legos??
E: What are "teenage level" legos?
M: It is a boat! E: (Laughing)
M: 'Cause this says "boat"!
(Ethan and Tyler laugh as Mark is happy at his own realization of this)
T: I think mine's a police... car
'Cause it says (Looks for word again)
M: 'Cause it says "lice" (as in police)
T: Lice (again, as in police)
E: I think mine says...
A truck (?)
E: 'cause it's got a licence plate- M: you're losing a piece
M, a little more panicked: you're losing a piece
Etha- ETHAN ETHAN!!! (panicky mark)
E: OOoooHHHHHhhhhHH NnnnnNNNN ooooOOOoooOO!!!!!
E: fuck
(he got it)
E: do you smell the pies? they smell good
M: (shushes) don't talk about the pies!
We can't talk about how we efficiently
stacked these recording like in television you
(new topic) if you wanna be a Youtuber and you're trying to get a lot of videos out
Try to stack your recording days all
in one and then you can get a lot done in
a little bit of time and if you stack them even
if you need to wait on one video
start another video wouldn't be so bad
And that's a little Markiplier tip for all you-
burgeoning (is that a word?) YouTubers out there
Tell them the definition of "burgeoning" (oh i guess that is a word)
E: Burgeoning: the-...
One who burgeons
In the fieeeeld
(thinking pause)
One who... likes to
Burgeon themselves to
(can't bs this effectively)
E: burgeon M: I just- I'm so glad
E: Shush.
Burgeon
M: I'm so glad I paid for all your improv lessons
E: You're welcome
M: How much time we got?
M: Boy
E: I've done nothing
E: (laughs)
M and T: (Laughing)
E: I dont understand how there's so many pieces